hi everyone welcome back to plays of the
week brought to you by ooto
TV the content shown in this video has
been submitted by various players to
ooto TV Clips are compiled weekly for a
series of videos highlighting specific
players of their gameplay for the Tekken
Community by no means was it reused or
stolen without permission to the
rightful
owner
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
the
[Music]
me
k
cut
[Music]
on
all
[Music]
we
great
nice combo
[Music]
excellent
can't over
[Music]
fight
perfect
[Music]
fight
KO
[Music]
KO it's
over
[Music]
KO
perfect
[Music]
thanks for watching be sure to leave a
like And subscribe also huge shout out
to our patreon supporters if you want to
further support this Channel and making
more content like these please visit the
link to our patreon page below the
description want to be featured in ooto
TV send in your Clips by following these
steps before you submit your Clips make
sure the quality of the video is clear
put your IGN as a file name for your
video limit submissions to three to five
Clips a week per category don't spam
submissions and don't send folders with
your Clips on it avoid full length
matches or just cut the clip you want on
the desired play Until the End of the
round next send your Clips via Dropbox
in the correct category you can always
find it on the description of every ooto
TV series Once you upload your video
file if it prompts you to give your name
just put in your
IGN also these are things you can do if
you're sending a recorded replay
[Music]
match
please understand that it may take some
time for some clips to be featured
because of the review
[Music]
process